[Music]
okay neither of you are doing the
handwork
um
so
remember to follow that projection here
i'm not shoving this elbow
the force you're seeing going back
is that
this hand is
you'd have to overpower me
go
i overcome
[Music]
but that's not the odd
do it again
maybe you're stronger but maybe i'm
faster
[Music]
baby i'm warm
okay
right way
won't pop in
that's
you're using her grip
you become group dependent like that
go
[Music]
you feel how your left hand pulls on her
grip that's what you're using to bring
her around
is
coming around
i don't need the other hand
i don't need to grip
other way i'm not gonna pull him
with this hand that's gonna make me grip
dependent grab the pendant okay
i'm interested in his elbow
but i'm not grabbing it either
and pouring it around
i'm
he has an energy
i'm going to adhere the energy and i
lead it around
i'm not grip depending not on his grip
not on his foot
not on my grip
not
you see
even though he's holding you
don't use it just extend
[Music]
then
not
don't activate the outer deltoid
lead
i want you i'm just demonstrating i
don't need to pull his his
grabbing do the form
stay within his grip
lead the elbow around
without
pulling lead the elbow around instead
okay
if you're pulling his grip
it's because you're not
in the middle
of the axis of rotation
you're to the outside
and in front
that's the only way you can pull
okay
good
[Music]
again
let's see how it's difficult for you to
not pull or to game it and get out of
the grip because you're doing the omote
angle and we're
[Music]
i'll put this on a grid
12 o'clock six o'clock okay he's coming
in with his left hand i'll move to eight
i'll take like eight to two
oh okay
goes the other angle
here
i'll take the four to ten
you see you already know
and uh
okay
same thing
[Music]
if i you can do it too when you're
subtle enough
same thing here he throws that stripe oh
that was all i needed i didn't really
have to deviate he goes to strike again
i don't have to deviate with my feet
[Music]
you see that is invisible or not yes
dude no i gotta
[Music]
not
as
on i'm gonna turn the other way
and let him go not as deep
[Music]
okay well you can't do it with movement
big movement
small movement
no movement
okay
hey
[Music]
i want you to know where you're entering
to
pay attention that
why did you enter there
to what end
[Music]
i think i have in my mind that we're
doing
okay
yeah we don't you
pay attention step behind your hip again
pay attention pay attention to your body
okay step behind your hip
okay right here uh pay attention what
happens to your
body her body as you're coming around
again slow slow slow slow slow
slow slow slow okay what's what are you
doing right now stay there
you're pulling her arm do you see that
and uh
what happened to what happened to our
center alignment on our arms and stuff
okay so put your arms back in your
center where you want
where do you want yeah there you go so
she the only way she could get where you
had her
was that you had to uh
pull her there so put her back where you
have your center okay
and uh now do the turn without losing
this center movement what's happening to
the to the to your left hand
what do you feel
you're starting to pull okay got it okay
so let's look at this
i'll duplicate the problem i go behind
his hip can you see
okay
and then if i keep this here
i can i can already feel i gotta pull
this this isn't where the elbow power
where the elbow energy is is where the
hand is okay
so this is why you first put it
you put in the elbow
where the energy is now
okay
again let's say
let's say i
i go behind
and let's say i am strong enough to do
that that little part right there but
say it would be the same problem he's
the one that has all the leverage
the
base and everything and if he's stronger
than me no i'm not gonna do it
okay
when i'm pulling my
various guards like we were doing
uh elbow knee escape
you were told to put your knees where
to start the process of escaping
where
yeah on the hip crease okay in front of
the leg
the legs
that's what you're doing here
here
okay
that kick
that you had experienced when i kicked
you
is what i'm going to
[Music]
immediately
deviate from
that kick you don't remember is that
sidekick right there
okay
goes in
into this crease and that's where his
elbow power
that's what i can manipulate
a technique
for example
where i go all the way to the back would
be something like hiding me naked so
he's up though
you see
and i'm going to deal with his hip kick
by getting all the way to the back but
i'm now on his spine
you're not on his elbow anymore
think about it
the elbow was here
and i moved it to here because that's
where the connection is
when i do it
here's his spine
and i move me there because that's where
the connection is okay so you got to
watch this lateral stuff
there's not much i would say try to
sophisticate your art and have no
lateral movement in your aikido because
you're only going to get your
outer deltoids in it so
here and that's what you
is
[Music]
turtle him
relatedly
don't bring this under you now
you had to bring it under you because
how weak it was
okay again if he's strong
yes this is making me stronger
but if my maximum strength
can't stop him
leave this out
do you understand so
don't
put it under you
so that you can feel strong
feel powerful in the sense that it
doesn't take any of your strength
to get him down
so now you're like but then i can't put
my
knees and elbows
just keep leading it instead of pushing
down here
keep leading it until he hits where you
need him to be
there we're done
okay
but even if
i can't do that
i wouldn't make a fetish
out of the
knee and the armpit knee at the wrist
positioning
and how i got there
is all crap okay wouldn't work okay
try to
focus in on that uh
i i'm i bring him around he's got no
balance over here do you see that so
eventually it'll lower
it'll lower just because he's falling
i'm not pushing him down but as he
starts to fall i stay i follow him i'm
following him you see
if i just bring him over there and i
don't follow him we disconnect
so as he starts to fall i'm staying with
him staying with him
it looks like and look because he goes
down my hands on his elbow and then
we're all power hungry
afraid people it looks like i'm pushing
him down but i'm not pushing him down
i'm leading him out
and then he falls he's falling and i
follow him
okay
now as the guy resists i don't think
we'll get there today but you might
he's going to try to regain his balance
with the other arm as he tries to put
his basic support back under his line of
gravity you see that
and he's going to push up
so here i have the ik adhesion but when
he pushes up he'll push into
the koku projection do you see that and
so you'll get almost like
he's coming around
it gets kind of staccato like because
it's like a bouncing ball but even then
every time you get projected down i have
to follow you okay the following is
going to be more difficult because the
drop is faster but you just stay with it
okay
so
whom
around change your minds
[Music]
okay
got it
um let's take the other hand out
and you can see it doesn't go under me
it doesn't go under me
and don't put it under me okay this is
where oh what if he tries to get his
base of support and then i'm jacked
again i'm fine
okay
so all that and more we didn't cover
today he's in the technique so try to
see it don't disturb the technique and
go oh you can
know that okay
try to see at least the details we
covered today okay
[Music]
okay let's go
pick it up